no
o
la forma en la que nos enfrentamos al
miedo nos hace diferentes
yo quiero que levanten las manos las
personas que han tenido miedo
pero sin miedos que nos dé hasta miedo
levanta la mano es decir que tenemos
miedo
y ante la mano las personas que tienen
mi obras de alturas
realmente desde que son muy chiquitos
nuestros papás nuestras abuelas nos
empiezan a infundir los miedos por todo
si les pasaba que nos es abuela no ser
mamás eran como mi hijo no se para ahí
mi hijo levante si mi hijo no empieza a
correr por todos lados desde que somos
muy chiquitos nos empiezan a
para infundir miedos por todo por correr
por no correr por saltar por
encaramarnos y realmente desde que somos
muy chiquitos somos escaladores innatos
cuando nosotros escalamos escalamos con
los pies y desde que somos chiquitos
estamos intentando escalar cuando
estamos gateando estamos intentando
escalar y realmente la escalada aunque
sí es un deporte que da da mucho miedo
no es un deporte que me permitió a mí
tener la capacidad de moverme para
conseguir mis sueños y a conseguir mis
metas
recuerdo mucho la primera vez que escale
la primera vez que escale
me tocaba hacer un rappel
y para los que no saben un rápel es
es una dinámica de la escalada donde tú
tienes que soportar te con la cuerda y
tú mismo vas
vas moviendo los mecanismos y vas
controlando tu descenso
realmente es más no estás entre no es
tan sencillo pero no es tan complejo yo
tuve 40 minutos la primera vez que el
instructor ya estaba cansada y me dijo
venga un papito agentes ya que es clima
gente que quiere escalar
yo creo que nosotros cuando nos
imaginamos no sea un deportista extremo
si nos imaginamos sin más para acuerpado
aún más súper simpático mucho estarán
pensando soy yo sí
y
realmente los deportistas extremos
que nos ven de hollywood que son esos
monos así sin camisa con tabla de surf
no son buenos y son realmente en
california en a ver un montón pero los
deportistas este no somos personas como
ustedes o son personas como como yo
que tenemos problemas que tenemos miedos
que tenemos diferentes circunstancias en
nuestra vida que nos hacen seres humanos
al ser un deportista extremo o escalar o
el hacer un deporte ya necesario llámese
parapente no nos hace invencibles no sé
si les ha pasado se han visto esas
escaleras que tienen unos huequitos si
yo no va escalando que no quiere que se
lamente por ahí
a mí eso me da mucho miedo también las
mariposas como lo dio juan ahorita le
tengo pánico a las alturas y ustedes se
preguntarán cómo una persona que escala
le tiene miedo a las alturas pues muy
sencillo realmente el miedo me hace
movilizarme y quiero que por lo segundo
pensemos que nos hace que afecta nos
causa el miedo a nosotros nos paraliza
nos mueve
y cuál es el efecto que nos da nosotros
como seres humanos el miedo es por esto
en la escalada y en el miedo
puede encontrar cuatro escenarios que
nos representan nosotros puede encontrar
cuatro escenarios donde yo estoy seguro
que ustedes están en alguno no es el
escenario en donde no hay poco miedo y
hay poca acción en la famosa zona de
confort
quieres ver que no pasa nada estamos
cómodos en la que nos sentimos seguros
en el que tengo mi salario tranquilo en
la que tengo mi puesto asegurado
en la que mi relación de pareja marcha
normal donde las relaciones con mis
familiares y con mis seres queridos en
marcha normal realmente acá en esta zona
no pasa nada y quiero partir también de
que el miedo es algo subjetivo lo que me
da miedo a mí no es lo mismo que le
también ustedes
después está otro escenario quiere ser
de mucha acción y poco miedo que es
donde yo digo voy a aprender un poco de
esas cosas que donde no me siento cómodo
y quiero ir a explorar y quiero montar
una empresa pues yo ya voy a ir a mirar
un tema de emprendimiento voy a leerme
un libro de startups voy a voy a cursar
un nuevo idioma es un empiezo realmente
a moverme pero que muy seguramente no me
ha causado ese movimiento grande sí y no
he tenido que hacer un gran esfuerzo
después de ésta
en este escenario que es en el escenario
que muchos hemos caído y es el escenario
del drama donde hay mucho miedo y poca
acción
qué es el escenario
donde me paraliza el miedo donde yo
decido no hacer nada porque mi vida está
tranquila donde es el escenario del
mínimo esfuerzo
donde es el escenario que me siento
vulnerable
en donde yo voy me da miedo la gente que
va a pensar uno que tal si no me salga
en la zona en donde se mostraba
es que no hay plata para eso no
o mejor dejémoslo para el otro año antes
demos que los chinos crezcan
y está el mejor escenario al escenario
de cambio el escenario de resiliencia es
el escenario en donde ocurre la magia
es donde yo
tengo mucho movimiento mucha acción
aunque tenga mucho miedo es cuando me
lanzó al agua es cuando yo quiero montar
mi empresa voy la monto
es que si quiere un ascenso en mi
empresa voy y tengo esa conversación
difícil con mi jefe
es donde si quiere aprender un deporte
extremo pues voy
y no importa que me cause golpes que me
conocen muchos dolores porque en la
valla que nos damos duro
y no solamente en la escalada
realmente en el ejercicio de la vida nos
damos duro intentando aprender cosas
pero es ahí en donde está el valor de
cómo enfrentamos el miedo y cómo
sorteamos esas situaciones
a través de la escalada yo empecé a
movilizarme y empecé a resignificar mi
vida desde tres factores fundamentales
la vulnerabilidad
el trabajo en equipo y la resiliencia
que la vulnerabilidad
la vulnerabilidad de ese miedo que
tenemos esa sensación de incertidumbre
que va a pensar las personas que van a
pensar lo que va a pasar en las
situaciones en las que no me siento
cómodo en las que no quiero que las
personas me vean débiles
la vulnerabilidad que creen ustedes que
es malo que es buena
la vulnerabilidad es todo esto pero que
nosotros seamos conscientes de que
aunque seamos vulnerables somos dignos
de que nos respeten
para mí la vulnerabilidad precisamente
estar allá es estar en la roca es estar
a 50 a 70 metros los niveles de
dificultad en la escalada si bien por ti
por diferentes circunstancias o por
diferentes niveles entre estos niveles
hasta el nivel de altura y el nivel de
exposición que tiene el cuerpo a la
caída
ahora imagínense ustedes de 50 a 70
metros que nada más lo sostenga una
cuerda
que cualquier movimiento te puede hacer
caer se puede hacer pegar incluso te
puede ocasionar la muerte
by sus sentidos vulnerables sentirás
vulnerables de sentir que cuando estamos
arriba en la roca nuestro cuerpo no va
más
que nos duele en los brazos porque
queremos ya estar abajo
y ahora quiero que piensen por un
momento cuando ustedes
abre las redes sociales de su celular
abren instagram
abren facebook y quieren a todos estos
gurús de la motivación diciéndonos no
pares sigue adelante para atrás ni para
impulso
qué pasa si paramos
qué pasa si nos sentimos vulnerables un
momento y te decimos
voy a parar
muchas veces el no parar significa de
pronto sacar nuestro cuerpo y eso lo que
nos pasa en la escalada si yo soy
consciente de que no puedo hacer una
ruta porque no tengo la condición física
cuando tengo toda la técnica debo parar
y decir no es el momento
cuántas veces ustedes se tienen un
momento en el día a día y dicen voy a
resignificar mi camino voy a parar un
momento porque nos da tanto miedo parar
eso yo lo aprendí
lo aprendiendo una de estas rutas que no
la podía hacer yo soy una persona muchas
veces un poco piscina y yo decía esa
tarde me acuerdo si puedo hacerlo si
puedo hacerlo así si puedo hacerla no
pude hacerla
me lastimé el cuerpo incluso llegué a
pegarle a la roca y me cortada la cuerda
de la persona que está abajo cuidándote
por más de que se hace el escalador más
experto siempre tienes una persona que
está abajo y cuidando tu cuerpo es la
cordada recordada me dijo
pero se llama negro o negro no vas a
poder hoy no vamos a poder hoy bajad
bajad bajad y yo le dije no no no yo
puedo hacerlo yo tengo que hacerlo
me miró y me dijo no vas a poder hoy
pero vas a poder dentro de 8 días
y ahí entendí la importancia del equipo
las personas que están al lado de
nosotros yo lo que significó desde la
escalada
pero después preguntó ustedes se sienten
felices se sienten contentos de la
cordada que tienen al lado también se
pareja llámese hijos llámese jefe
llámese compañero de trabajo novia
para que quiero contarles una historia
y recuerdo mucho cuando
mi abuela me decía a mí a mi hijo no se
vaya a caer mi hijo y la no corra por
ahí hay que pasar al instante conoce que
está súper duro
las abuelas tienen tienen un don las
mamás y las acciones son como pitonisa
si ya lo saben todo
ellos tienen el don de adivinar que la
pasará uno
cuando yo salía corriendo me decían se
va a caer me caía
pero lo que más recuerdo de mi abuela
fue una frase que quiero que por favor
usted me ayudará a complementar y quiera
dime con quién andas
y no solamente tenían razón desde desde
el ser mamá
tienes que científicamente tienen la
razón nosotros somos el resultado de las
cinco o seis personas que nos rodean con
las que más tenemos relación
en mi caso
ella es mi abuela ella la persona que me
ha inspirado a hacer lo que soy
jaime garzón es la persona que me motivó
a estudiar comunicación social y
periodismo eso es un referente para que
veamos que si somos el resultado de las
personas que nos rodean o de los líderes
que admiramos y las personas que me
rodean dentro del mundo de la escalada
es este señor me chulito carlos
saldarriaga
qué es una persona que cuando tuve una
situación difícil lo mismo vamos a
tomarnos una pola dijo vamos a escalar
la preparación ya mí no me importa
ese es el tipo de personas
que te retan ya eso me refiero con la
acordada la acordada la persona que te
reta y que te desafía siempre a ser
mejor
l juan los instructor que iniciamos como
amateurs aquí iniciamos sin tener ni
idea y en la actualidad
el mico workers
y junto a él
desarrollamos capacitaciones y
formaciones a grupos empresariales ya
personas y ya no solamente un instructor
también mi amigo
después encontramos la resiliencia y la
resiliencia es esto que desde las
organizaciones y desde la universidad no
nos han dicho que es la capacidad de
cambiar y adaptarnos
y precisamente es eso la resiliencia es
la capacidad que tenemos de adaptarnos y
cuando nos adaptamos
nos adaptamos a partir del entrenamiento
nos adaptamos a partir de adquirir
nuevos hábitos descubiertos una cultura
ya mi adaptación la hice a través de
entrenamiento mi adaptación la hice a
través de aprender nuevos pasos que para
la escalada me han permitido
a cada día hace rutas mucho más
difíciles
tradicional me da cuenta que yo me he
vuelto el instructor el profesor y la
guía y la cordada para muchas personas
soy soy esa persona que para los que
están arriba están esperando de mí que
las cuide
ahora pensemos nosotros para quien somos
esa persona
y si realmente si estamos valorando y si
estamos actuando como una cordada
hay gente que nos admira hay gente que
espera mucho de nosotros pero lo más
importante que me ha dejado en la
escalada es la capacidad de tener
perspectiva de tener por perspectiva
y quiero que por un segundo por 10
segundos cierren los ojos y piensen
dónde están hoy con sus títulos con sus
hijos dónde venían hoy de su trabajo y
que se pregunten
todo lo que ha pasado para que lleguen
acá
todo lo que pasaba para que lleguen hoy
a su casa y tengan un plato de comida
para que tengan a sus hijos estudiando
en un colegio
para que este fin de semana se puedan ir
a la finca para que mañana tenga clase
en una universidad
pregúntese en todo lo que ha pasado
porque precisamente la perspectiva es
eso
vas a entender dónde estás
y como llegaba ahí
y es por eso
que para mí la escala es
meditación en movimiento para mí la
escalada es la capacidad de poder ver el
mundo en perspectiva y la escalada me ha
enseñado que todas mis metas y todos mis
objetivos son posibles siempre y cuando
nos movamos muchas gracias
[Música]
vivo
i